youtube is by far the most popular video
sharing platform in the world most of us
associate youtube with google and given
that google acquired youtube very early
on and the fact that google has poured
in billions to keep youtube up and
running i do think google deserves most
of the credit for youtube success today
with that being said though google did
not actually found youtube they actually
bought youtube for 1.65 billion dollars
from three guys in october of 2006. so
how did these three guys end up founding
youtube what have they been doing since
the acquisition and where are they today
starting off we have jawed kareem kareem
was born on october 5th 1979 in mursburg
east germany both of his parents worked
as researchers his father was a
researcher at 3m and his mother was a
biochemistry researcher at the
university of minnesota
at a very young age kareem and his
family would leave communist east
germany and immigrate to west germany
and this is where kareem spent most of
his early childhood at age 12 or 13
kareem would move once again this time
to saint paul minnesota kareem ended up
attending the local high school there
called saint paul central high school
and eventually he would end up attending
the university of illinois at
urbana-champaign
like many tech founders kareem ended up
leaving campus to become an employee at
paypal
however he did not actually drop out
kareem continued his education remotely
and finished up his bachelor's in
computer science while working at paypal
this wasn't a fast process by any means
though as it took him seven years to
earn his bachelor's
but he did end up graduating eventually
in the meantime kareem met two guys at
paypal who he would end up founding
youtube with according to kareem the
motivation for creating youtube came
from his inability to find popular clips
online
apparently kareem was unable to find
clips of the 38th super bowl halftime
show or the 2004 indian tsunami online
at the start of 2005 kareem and the two
fans from paypal acquired a domain
youtube.com and develop the website over
the next few months
around the same time kareem would record
and post the first video on youtube on
april 23 2005 called me at the zoo
though korean played a key role in the
initial development of youtube kareem
actually stepped away quite early on
while kareem enjoyed entrepreneurship he
also loved education and he preferred to
spend his time pursuing a graduate
degree instead of building youtube
kareem would later admit that this
decision was definitely not the norm
anyway kareem served as an informal
advisor to youtube as he completed his
master's in computer science at stanford
but this decision significantly reduces
payout from youtube when google bought
youtube korean received a total of a 137
443 shares of google which was worth
about 64 million dollars at the time
if he held on to that stake he would
easily be on the path to becoming a
billionaire today
but kareem really had no interest in the
billionaire lifestyle kareem says that
while his success in entrepreneurship is
great he just wants to be a professor
unfortunately it doesn't seem like
kareem actually ended up becoming a
professor or at least there's no
indication of that online however kareem
did end up going down the education path
as opposed to the building a retirement
path kareem finished up his masters at
stanford and co-founded a company called
university ventures or why ventures
through y ventures kareem and a couple
of other distinguished entrepreneurs
basically offered mentorship consulting
and access to capital to up-and-coming
startups some of the biggest companies
they've worked with are airbnb reddit
palantir postmates and open door aside
from helping other startups kareem was
also notable for opposing google's
decision to mandate google plus accounts
to comment on youtube in 2013 but that's
pretty much it with kareem
after youtube he basically just
continued his education and went on to
invest into it and coach other startups
moving on we have chad hurley who was
definitely the most involved co-founder
of youtube chad was born on january 24th
in 1977 in reading pennsylvania
unlike many other tech founders who are
extremely talented in stem subjects chad
was actually quite artistically inclined
in fact he often sold many of his
sketches and artworks during his
elementary school days as he moved into
high school he did develop a passion for
technology
but even then technology wasn't the
focal point of his life throughout high
school chad was a star runner in the
school's cross country program and he
even won two pennsylvania state titles
in 1992 and 1994.
moving on to college chad actually
revisited his childhood passion and
ended up majoring in fine arts at the
indiana university of pennsylvania after
university like reem chad also ended up
at paypal but he wasn't working on the
tech side chad was actually working on
paypal's ui and the company's logo
chad also has a different story when it
comes to the origins of youtube chad
claims that the inspiration for creating
youtube came from his inability to share
videos from a dinner party online
anyway whichever one is the real story
after the trio founded youtube in early
2005 chad became the company's first ceo
though he was technically a ceo his
initial responsibility mainly consisted
of managing the tagging and video
sharing aspects of youtube in 2006 chad
was ranked 28th on business 2.0 list of
50 people who matter now
i think business 2.0 was spot on with
chad during the acquisition chad would
walk away with the biggest cash out out
of the three founders he received a
total of 694 087 shares of google
directly and 41 232 shares of google
through a trust
in total this added up to a solid 345
million dollars or over five times more
than kareem chad didn't leave youtube
after the acquisition either in fact
chad actually stayed ceo of youtube up
until the end of 2010 when he resigned
to focus on other business endeavors
right after he stepped away from youtube
chad co-founded avos systems avos
systems was an incubator company that
enabled app developers to develop and
test their apps in real time the company
originally operated as an incubator and
helped develop several apps but chad
always had his eye on one specific app
which was mixbit mixbit was a mobile
video sharing platform and chad hoped
that he could revolutionize mobile video
sharing with mixbit just like you
revolutionize computer based video
sharing with youtube but as we now know
youtube ended up dominating the mobile
space as well though mixbit never
reached the heights of youtube the
project wasn't a complete waste in 2018
blue jeans bought certain parts of
mixbit with plans of implementing the
technology into enterprise video
conferencing solutions in the meantime
chad has made a couple of notable
investments within the sports world as
well
in 2014 chad bought a part of the la
football club with magic johnson
later on he invested into the golden
state warriors and just earlier this
year he invested into leeds united
football club aside from sports teams
chad even invested into a formula one
team called usf1 team in 2009
but unfortunately this team never
actually ended up competing and that's
pretty much what chad's been up to he
stayed as youtube ceo after the
acquisition he tried to create a mobile
video sharing platform and he bought a
couple of sports teams here and there
and that brings us into youtube's last
co-founder steve chen steve chen was
born on august 25 1978 in taipei taiwan
steve spent the first eight years of his
life in taiwan after which his family
moved to prospect heights illinois steve
attended local middle schools and high
schools before enrolling in the
university of illinois at
urbana-champaign just like karim at
university he majored in computer
science and he would graduate in 2002
following his education he of course got
a job at paypal where he met kareem and
chad but unlike the other two steve
didn't jump straight into youtube steve
actually got a job at facebook and he
worked there for several months before
diving into youtube at youtube steve was
appointed as the chief technology
officer where he ensured that youtube
could support all of the incoming
traffic
in 2006 steve was also ranked 28 on
business 2.0 list of 50 people who
matter now alongside chad and later that
year during the acquisition steve
received almost the same cash out as
chad steve received 625 366 shares of
google directly and 68 721 shares
through a trust at the time the shares
were worth 325 million dollars but now
they're worth 1.78 billion dollars like
chad steve stayed at youtube after the
acquisition up until 2009. in 2009 he
left youtube but he stayed at google
however he would leave google as well in
2011 to start a new company with chad
which was of course avos systems steve
was super interested in developing an
incubator platform for app developers
but he wasn't that interested in
creating another video sharing platform
so when chad wanted to pivot avos
systems into mixbit steve would leave
the company it wasn't an intense
corporate fallout or anything like that
though steve and chad simply
respectfully chose to go different ways
as chad went on to develop mixbid steve
would go back to google joining google
ventures google ventures focuses on
investing into startups and helping them
grow and they're basically another
company incubator given that this is
what steve was interested in doing with
avos systems it's not surprising that
google ventures is where he ended up
in 2016 steve actually launched
something called nom.com this website
was focused on live streaming food
related content created by users
ironically steve parted ways with chad
because he did not want to create
another video sharing platform but just
a couple of years later that's exactly
what he ended up doing
unfortunately though this never didn't
last too long and would be shut down
just one year later in 2017 for unknown
reasons nonetheless in 2018 steve was
inducted as a laureate of the lincoln
academy of illinois and he received the
order of lincoln which is the highest
honor given by the state later on in
august of 2019 steve decided to move
back to taiwan with his family and he's
been living there ever since
it looks like steve perfectly timed that
move considering what would transpire
just a couple of months later
but that's pretty much it for steve
at the end of the day kareem chad and
steve all ended up working at some sort
of incubator company chad and steve
dabbled with a bit of video sharing once
again
but both of them eventually ditched
these efforts
and ironically all three of these guys
keep a pretty low profile online
preferring a life of peace and quiet
were you guys familiar with the founders
of youtube comment that down below
also drop a like if you're grateful
these guys founded youtube and of course
consider joining our discord community
to suggest future video ideas and to
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
you